what's going on guys today i have some
really exciting news to update you on
and i'm just gonna get straight to it
the release date for my hero
is confirmed to be in spring of 2021
now this information comes from atsushi
on twitter
who i can vouch for is an incredibly
reliable source they always have this
information ahead of time
and you know their source according to
their twitter is
shonen jump issue 44 which will be
coming out on sunday
so this is not too much of a surprise
because
when we look back at seasons one to
three you know season one came out in
early april season two came out in early
april season three came out in early
april
season four was really the only outlier
so
this is basically a return to normalcy
and uh yeah
my hero season 5 is coming out most
likely in april
but definitely in spring so i guess
march technically counts as spring as
well so
maybe we'll get it a bit earlier but but
i doubt it earlier this year i did a
video
explaining what storylines will likely
be covered but i did this in a
spoiler-free way so you you don't really
know what's gonna happen but you just
get a very
vague overview so i would recommend
checking that out if you're a little bit
curious
i'm pretty excited about this i was just
waiting for a confirmation
uh i was hoping slyly i was hoping that
maybe we would get something this year
although i i knew my heart of hearts
that wouldn't happen but
i was kind of hoping for it um but yeah
spring
not too surprising i'm not really gonna
drag this video out as i'm currently
working
on a new list video which should be out
this week um so i'm gonna get back to
that
but yeah just wanted to update you guys
season 5 2021
be ready until the next one peace out